hello everyone and thank you for tuning
in to this HD video and welcome to a
screencast for Chris Pirillo at
youtube.com slash Lockergnome and
Lockergnome calm in this video I'm going
to cover the chris pirillo network which
include his YouTube channel his website
personal blog and a social networking
site also sherry ways which you can
connect with the man himself Chris
Pirillo and all this is a demonstration
of video of my screen casting abilities
for collaboration with youtube.com slash
Lockergnome so let's just get right into
this guy's the Lockergnome youtube
channel does boast some impressive
statistics which include his channel
views youtube subscribers and even his
date of joint he has more than 3.8
million channel views a little close to
ninety thousand subscribers and he
joined in april of 2006 and on the right
hand side of this channel you can see
all of the links he has his twitter his
social networking site and a number of
other really nice lengths and i will
leave the link to his YouTube channel
where he can find all these links in the
description of this video the videos he
produces here are sort of an educational
style and so are the other channels that
he does link to up here at the media hub
of the Lockergnome network which include
householdhacker and I do productions we
both might have heard of very popular
youtubers along with Locker number if we
scroll down here to the bottom of his
youtube channel we can do the honors
that is accumulated during his long time
on YouTube which include the number 28
most subscribed guru of all time on
YouTube a very worthy accomplishment
congrats to chris
first I want to take you to one of the
first links on his channel which is
chris pirillo com his personal blog
where I posts a number of noteworthy
posts that actually do read on a daily
basis these include technology videos
and technology posts as well as other
things about interesting things that he
considers to be tech related one of them
the featured one on this page is what
will the internet look like in 10 years
an interesting prospect and there are a
lot of articles like this on chris
pirillo com
the next link i want to show you guys is
the link to his website Lockergnome com
which is actually the place where he
posts most of his tech news and things
that he finds the most interesting and
relevant in the world of technology you
can also subscribe to the RSS feed by
clicking the RSS logo and this is also a
site i visited quite frequently because
of the quality of information he posts
here it's a really nice website you guys
can check that out again at the link to
his YouTube channel in the description
so I'd like to end this little demo
screencast by showing you the ways that
you can connect with Kris Furillo so I'm
going to first demonstrate show you guys
his Twitter which actually has a large
number of followers and a huge amount of
success and that is twitter.com / Chris
Pirillo he has about 75,000 Twitter
followers as you can see and he's
following about 60 people himself and
here he tweets that the websites that
he's posted on and the his blog post and
his locker known posts so this is really
cool that you guys can connect with them
here secondly you can do his live stream
at Christopher locom / live or live
pirillo com and he's constantly typing
away and answering you guys emails and
this is just a sneak peek at that and
you can of course view that at the link
in the description last but not least is
his email you can obviously find him by
Google and Chris and it'll be the first
result and you can connect with him just
by emailing him simply at chris @
pirillo com so hope you guys enjoyed
this short little video demonstrating
and showing you guys the Christopher
locom network and I hope you guys like
this little tour and I'll hopefully
connect a few guys again in the next
video that I produce so thank you guys
for watching peace